There's one last set of concepts
I'd like to cover before we move into some actual programming.
This is ACID.
Now again, like many of the concepts in this lecture,
this is a very, very broad topic,
and we're just barely going to scratch the surface.
But I want you to be familiar with these concepts,
because this is the type of language we'll be using when we're building a system.
ACID--this stands for
Atomicity, Consistency, Isolation, Durability.
Atomicity refers to the notion that
all parts of a transaction succeed or fail together.
Now, we haven't talked about transactions,
but these are basically just a group of statements.
So if we were updating our database,
which is actually not something we spend much time on,
there may be the case where we're updating two tables at once,
or updating multiple rows in our database together,
in one cohesive unit.
For example, if we're working from the Reddit example,
if we had a link table and a users table,
and somebody up voted on a link and that increases the user's reputation,
we might increase the score of the link
and also increase the reputation of the user.
And then what happens is something called a transaction,
which groups together multiple commands.
Atomicity refers to the notion that either all those commands are going to succeed,
or they're all going to fail, but we don't do part of it.
We don't have just updating the link and not updating the user.
Everything happens together.
So this is a nice property for a database to have.
Consistency refers to the notion that
the database will always be consistent.
And to work from our Reddit example, let's talk about this idea
where we have a link and a user who have properties.
If we have this notion that
a link has a score
that gets updated periodically,
and the author--or the submitter--of that link
also has a karma score that also gets updated at the same time,
consistency refers to the notion that both the score and the karma
will be consistent with one another
so that we don't update the score
without also updating the karma.
It basically means the database will move from one valid transaction to the next.
So we'll never run a query that gets a links updated score
but can't also get the user's updated karma.
So isolation refers to the notion that
no transaction can interfere with another's.
So let's say we have a link that is both getting
two votes coming at the same time
to increase the score of this link.
That means we're going to be updating the links score
up and down and the user's karma up and down.
Isolation refers to the notion that
this up vote won't affect
the computation of this down vote.
If we were overriding this link in our database,
it would be a shame if the down vote was applied to
the original link score before the up vote was applied.
Because then that score changing here should be 0,
but it could be -1 if these aren't handled properly.
So isolation refers to the notion that each transaction
cannot affect other transactions.
Sometimes this is accomplished through locking.
If two transactions affect the same row,
only one can go at a time.
And there are other ways of resolving transaction conflicts like that.
Isolation refers to a database's ability to do that.
Finally, we have durability.
Durability refers to the notion that once a transaction is committed,
it won't be lost.
This means that, for example, if we send an update to our database,
and we update some rows,
and the database says, okay, successful,
that even if the database is turned off or crashed,
crashes, or is unplugged, we won't lose that data.
That is durability.
One thing I'd like you to know--
I know we introduced a lot of new concepts in this portion here,
but the important takeaway from this
is that when you're talking about different database systems,
you have different tradeoffs.
It's hard to be fully--have a database that's completely atomic,
it's completely consistent, all transactions are isolated,
and it's completely durable.
There's always some tradeoffs.
So for example, let's take a little quiz.
Replication lag is the example of the loss of which property--
Atomicity, Consistency, Isolation, or Durability?
Now, remember replication lag--we discussed this--
I'll go over it again real quick--
occurs in this situation.
So we've got a master database.
We've got a couple of slaves.
Replication lag occurs when we send a write to the master
and we want to replicate it to our slaves,
but we don't finish replicating it
when a read comes in directly to one of the slaves.
Now, we allow these reads to come in directly to the slaves,
remember, to alleviate some of the read load from our master.
But if the data hasn't propagated yet, this is called replication lag.
So which property is this an example of losing?